he posted this uh
selfie sort of uh right and and there's
they're reading into it saying that
there's a tattoo that says kim
um yeah he has a few tattoos few cute
ones you know that he got um but this
one is a it's not that one the kim one
isn't a tattoo it's actually a branding
like a
branding
kim kardashian is revealing the latest
gesture her boyfriend pete davidson made
for her and you're hearing that right
the snl star has a branding of the
beauty mogul's name
on his chest
why not eagle-eyed fans pointed out in
this photo of pete that kim's name was
on his chest which they thought was a
tattoo
turns out it's a brand when you say
branding so like literally like an iron
thing yes went on to his body yes to
brand kim yes uh-huh
and on top of the iron imprint the
reality star says pete already has a few
tattoos in her honor the branding is my
name right the other ones are like
cutesy things i think my favorite one
it says here it says my girl is a lawyer
and that one's really cute wow yeah
that's amazing that one's really cute
okay first tattoo we got i was like oh
so cute thank you oh my god you know
second whatever i'm like oh that's so
cute but like that's what tattoo people
do right like they get tattoos of what's
going on in their life it's really lit
and fun and crazy kim then reveals why
pete chose to go the permanent route i
don't know like i
i just think he was like i want
something that's there that i can't
you know get rid of my tattoos because
he's in the process of getting rid of
his arm cats
and his neck hats so he's like i don't
want to be able to get rid of it or to
cover it up and i just wanted it like
there as like a scar
on me it's so cute guys and that cute
gesture follows the couple going
instagram official last week kim shared
these sweet snapshots of their time
together which is something the skims
founder wanted to share with the world i
have the cutest pictures of us and i
want to be like oh my god we're so cute
and i want you know but then i'm like
you know
don't be so desperate don't be posting
so much just give a glimpse and someone
who has the full support of the two's
romance kim's bestie jonathan chabon as
one of kim's closest confidants what do
you think of her and pete together oh i
think it's cool you know what she's
having fun i guess you know uh you know
i i've hung out with them a couple of
times and
you know i love her to death so whatever
whatever makes her happy and kim makes
it very clear her happiness is coming
from pete at the moment no matter what
it is i just think i encourage my
friends and my the people that i love
just to be happy and i went for it and i
went for it i was like you know what i'm
in my 40s like
sorry like just go for it find your
happiness yeah and like i went for it
and i took my time and i found it and it
feels so good and i want to hold on to
that forever
[Music]
you